now this next part of the question the
last part of question is the best part
because it really requires you to think
a lot of this is somewhat mindless like
you're differentiating or integrating
you have substituted values in that's
all pretty straightforward Reba's last
part with me and read it carefully it's
all about interpreting this in terms of
all this it says suppose that it's
necessary to let out a total of 300
cubic meters from the tank how long
should the tap your left fully on before
gradually turning it off so here's the
idea right put your pins down for a
second
you've got the tank of water okay hey it
starts out what did we say it started at
520 okay so let's just call that 520
cubic meters okay now we can watch it
the turf turns on and water starts to
clot and if we want to release 300 cubic
meters then when we want to stop is at
all on this scale something like that
we want there to be 220 cubic meters
left at the end does that make sense but
of course you cannot wait until you see
the water line past that mark cuz why
not why can't you wait until that point
because then you've actually released
too much because once you've seen that
oh I better start turning this thing off
now but I can't do it
in fluent that was the whole premise of
the question so therefore I have to slow
down and do that I actually have to stop
the water earlier than when it hits 220
when do I need to stop it
yeah I need to stop it
when I hit 240 right or in other words
rather than having released 300 oh no
release 280 okay that's because as I
then go and turn off the tap this amount
of water will also make it out while I'm
turning off the tap does that make sense
so here's the way I'm going to yes
ah okay so this is interesting right
because the first thing you might think
is it's not to Eddie I want the volume
to end up as 240 don't I and then I
start to shut off but there becomes a
problem right um don't don't write this
down please don't this down you'll see
why in a second let's suppose I try and
solve where's my volume function uh here
it is
he's my volume function okay so I'm just
gonna start to take this as my
assumption right I minus 2 T Square
sorry minus 2 T plus T squared all of 20
plus 5 21 it to be equal to what again I
wanted to get to 242 okay so I'm just
gonna try and solve this and see what
happens the first thing I notice is
let's this is a quadratic let's get the
right term at the front this is he
what's the constants to 80 all right
okay I just just hold on for a second
stay with me
this is a bit messy I don't like these
fractions and all that kind of thing so
I'm gonna multiply through by 20 is
there reason why I can't do that the
right hand side zero so I'm gonna get
this what's that okay now just pause for
a second what asking you to solve this I
just want you to think about this
equation and what your spider-sense told
you right now we know like if you if you
grab this okay if you graph this yeah
okay I've got my wrist here and here
zero and 40 yeah that okay and then what
does this do this list you are
it lets you up thousands of units into
the air right so our quadratic which
looks just used to look like this right
is now somewhere up here and when we
apparently want it to be equal to zero I
don't like our chances right if that's
if that's not enough for you you just
have a look at this and you say well I
can work out whether I'm gonna go to the
show or not like without this guesswork
I just think about the discriminative B
squared take away 4ac
that's gonna be so negative it's not
even funny
this has no solution okay well now this
is the flow ray right so you want it to
be equal to what do you want it to be
equal to now I'm gonna ask you to come
back to the question come back come back
it says it's necessary to let a total of
300 meters cubed from the tangles how
long should the tap be left fully on all
this time we've actually been answering
the wrong question there's nothing to do
with this at the moment right remember
let's write it down this way okay if
we're going to lose 20 cubic meters
right at the very end as we turn off the
tap okay something she gonna back this
down recall and maybe you want to do
this with me Maplin party 20 cubic
meters are released as the tap is turned
off as I'm slowly turning okay so as a
consequence I want 280 cubic meters to
be released not when the tap is being
turned off like when the tap is fully on
but hold on a second when the tap is
fully on I know exactly how much water
is leaving the tank every second it was
the first question I answered right pate
what is flowing out at 2 q 8 meters per
second at time zero when the tap is
fully on so therefore how many seconds
is it going to take if you're losing in
two cubic meters every second therefore
it takes 280 divided by 2 that's every
second I'm losing two cubic meters
seconds to empty or to lose release
maybe it's better with right does that
make sense
do you see how like it's so easy to just
are go to the equation start solving
something no no no no think first solve
second right it's easy to go to
equations and start putting numbers in
right but this is the dudes Nissan who
understands these mooks carefully and
and does your planning before you start
working on what's going on and it's just
division then a calculus involved we've
already worked out the full ray so in
there for 140 seconds what's that
2 minutes and 20 seconds well I should
say the tax should be to take the exact
wording of the question I think they
would say the tap is fully on for two
minutes
okay so now you have the scenario in
your head right you turn it on off it
goes two minutes and twenty seconds
passed and this amount of water gets
released in that time and then you start
to turn the tap and you turn it slowly
and slowly and eventually that 280 just
comes up to 300 and then at that point
it's fully off okay so this is why I
picked this as an example right it's way
too easy to just treat the algebra as
everything right but it's all about how
you use the algebra and like what
numbers need to be combined and in what
ways read the questions Super's should
be carefully right it's all about
interpreting that properly that's really
what this topic is about okay does
anyone any questions just seem clear I'm
sorry I led you down a bit of rabbit
hole I had to so that you can see it's
not so simple as just are the equations
will tell me the equations will not tell
you everything you need to use them
carefully okay and that's your job not
the equations job